Maurice jones-drew he is the NFL Network
analyst and I think working the Rams
game tonight so are you working the Rams
game tonight mojo yes I am dan how are
you sir I'm good sir can you have too
much talent on a team I never think you
can have too much talent especially well
it just depends if you have a lot of
guys that are outspoken then maybe yes
but if you have a ton of talent where
guys understand the systems and there
shouldn't be a problem at all
well maybe can you have too many
personalities on a team it all depends I
think Jacksonville has a ton of
personalities but they find a way to
make it work everybody on that Jags
defense feels like they're the best I
mean and it makes me defensively you
have to have a ton of personalized
offensively you need your quarterback to
be that alpha male that kind of can
drive and make sure everyone knows what
they're doing and they you know become
that real leader what we look at the
Rams there's a lot of talent there but
what what could be the negative here for
you a bigger picture with them their
depth they they have they don't have a
lot of depth right now but they have a
lot of front first starters that are
very talented but you're looking at the
depth behind when you you look at a team
even though they lost this week in the
New Orleans Saints when we played him in
the week when the Rams played in week
four
they had their bag the guys were playing
the fourth preseason game good you know
second third string guys were all four
or five year players so that's what you
you want to kind of be able to grow to
and Sean Payton the Saints have done a
great job with that
I think the Rams are on their way
building that right now obviously when
you're you know spitting out the money
you spend you're going to be able to
keep guys only on their first contract
then have to kind of groom some new
younger players but they're getting
there
I want to say they're about a year to a
way to having that the depth that you
need when you know to make a run at the
Super Bowl what did you make of Aaron
Rodgers night last night listen I mean
first thing I thought of my mind can't
well the first thing they came in was
Paul Pierce right you remember at palmas
against the Lakers back in the day gets
carried off
field off the court and then put in the
wheelchair and then also and comes back
I mean listen I'm not a I can't really
speak on it but the Packers chances will
go into the Super Bowl that have gone up
ever since then really about that that
was that was Aaron Rodgers is Paul
Pierce moment the Celtics didn't win the
championship in LA so teams got to be
prepared for that
Khalil Mack nice little debut for him
but I was surprised that Jon Gruden
didn't reach out to clone actor in these
negotiations and just almost say how do
we make this work how surprised were you
that it almost feels like the Raiders
really had no interest in Andrey signing
him well I'll say this this is kind of
after doing a ton of research and
getting my emotions out because I grew
up a Raiders fan this is kind of what
Gruden has done throughout his whole
coaching tenure he always keeps he tries
to get veteran defensive guys on lower
deals doesn't like to play it pay his
defensive guys but loves to pay his
offensive guys so you saw what he did in
Tampa he won the Super Bowl traded or or
not traded but got rid of Sapp got her a
Simeon rice some older veteran guys kind
of came in to try to replace those guys
so but that's his his playbook that's
his scheme that's what he wants to do he
doesn't like to pay the big-time players
on defense he loves to pay the guys on
office Granny's offensive guy but Khalil
Mack when I was there then I was a up I
was in year nine Khalil Mack was a
rookie we knew from day one the day he
walked in the building and started
working out that there was something
different about him soon as we got the
pads on you saw the way he he rushed the
passer both as a linebacker as a
defensive end the way he ran to the ball
the way he did the things he did as a
rookie we knew that he would he had the
potential of being a Hall of Fame player
those guys you just can't allow ability
I don't care what your your scheme is or
your philosophy those are guys that
change those and you need like you said
you need talent to win you know I was I
was told once by a coach how coaches are
graded when you have good players you're
a good coach you have great players
you're great codes when you have bad
players you're fine
and so that's that's what it comes down
to you need players to win in this game
and you have to have talent around you
to be able to make some plays that are
off script ie Aaron Rodgers and what he
was able to do after coming back and
make him plays off script or you know
Khalil Mack find a way to get the ball
out where you need guys to do the extra
the little things that help you get
ahead in games Maurice jones-drew NFL
Network analyst joining us Dan Patrick
show what advice would you give sake one
Berkeley I mean stay patient
I thought early in the game watching it
he was a little he trying to hit the big
run run you just have to stay patient I
do it they'll come to you you know the
offensive line will settle in you played
arguably the best defense or one of the
top two defenses in the league in
Jacksonville and you're able to break a
big run when they win it you know when
that opportunity presented itself but
don't try to go 70 80 yards every time
continue to take the four or five
because when you take the four and five
in the first quarter second quarter that
becomes seven eight third quarter that
becomes 10 to 12 and then fourth quarter
it becomes the 60 70 yard runs I think
that's great advice and I I felt like
there was a little bit of Barry Sanders
there where he was dancing a little bit
get one yard lose a yard get three yards
and then he gets 68
I gotta have him lower his head I got to
have him going in there and you know
getting four in five yards occasionally
and not trying to just set it up you
know for a home run well Dan you know we
can't lower our heads anymore so you
have a different terminology your
shoulder yeah lower your shoulder yeah
there we go I don't want you to get guys
fine cuz okay they were listening to us
know getting throw why we could get fine
hopefully not suspended but fined if
your lady on bail did the Steelers game
plan get your attention yesterday with
James Connor
oh no question and I think that's why
avions are not there because they have
too many touches for James Connor
oh listen again he has to weigh his
potential of getting injured ie what
happened to Aaron Rodgers someone falls
in your leg you can't you're done and
then the potential of an
big payday right and so this is a
business decision I wrote an article on
nfl.com about it that if I could do it
all over again when I held out a cup
with six years ago that I should have
waited till week ten one to show to
prove my worth to the team and two to
conserve my body because I think whether
it was a bye week seven I end up
breaking my foot and then that was kind
of into my career after that I couldn't
really bounce back from it so you know I
haven't I wrote an article saying that
we know that Pittsburgh and what they
like to do they're gonna run their guys
that's a Pittsburgh will so they're
gonna run the ball and they're gonna do
everything to see James Connor get 31
touches how many touches you think maybe
on Bell would have got then and 31 most
bills were carries yeah the only 31
carries in five catches so you can go 31
carries and 10 catches my lady on yeah
31 carries and eight catches my lady on
and that's I mean again they're gonna
win him into the ground you're starting
off week one of a 16-game season almost
getting 40 touches so you're talking
let's just what 40 times 16 they didn't
have a calculator over there I am a math
well as for that's what 400 and a lot
that's gives a lot of times over 400
types again and so that's why you have
to protect yourself in these situations
from these teams because the team in
their mind all they want to do is win a
championship they don't care about your
kids they don't care about your family
the next man
the next man up model is a great
responding 14 million dollars you got to
get something out of him well so but
this is the thing what is 14 million
dollars when you see David Johnson get
30 million over three years and he get
Todd Gurley gets 45 over six right
that's not that's not market value and
and LaVey understands that he's an
exceptional player and he's get paid as
such now we talk about all the time what
we don't talk about talk about all the
time is knowing your Worth and this is
this is a great thing so in the
franchise tag isn't really the worst of
what Le'Veon Bell is Le'Veon Bell isn't
just a running back he's a dynamic
offensive weapon that deserves to get
paid as such
because there wasn't a guy out there
that had that deal yet Pittsburgh
shouldn't have been afraid to go out
there and set the market with their
player but they were and this is the
consequence with that yeah I just I find
it difficult to believe that labia and
Bell he wants to conserve himself
because he doesn't care about the
Steelers he doesn't care about his
teammates no no we don't because he's
not gonna be there next year
mojo he's not gonna be there next year
so all he cares about
isn't but Dan that doesn't mean he
doesn't care about his teammates okay so
let me say this if someone came right
now let another network offered you more
money than you're making aren't you
gonna leave for the most part my kids
you if you got a better deal you would
you would you would try to leave that's
that's I've seen it multiple times not
not with me I've been offered I was
offered better money to leave ESPN a
couple of times it never did that I've
been offered money to leave what I have
now and I've turned that down I would
not do but I couldn't I couldn't do that
I mean this is I understand that that
it's a short career you have he's two
years older than todd gurley I think lay
beyond Bella's earning potential I know
but he doesn't care what happens to the
Steelers this year right Dan but listen
no this is this so let me let me paint
this picture for you no he played on the
franchise tag last year he came in
Pittsburgh said we're gonna get the deal
done to end the year we just need you to
come and do your thing he does it for
under touches last year they gave me
gave him three times getting hit didn't
they give him a three years you know
don't even they don't even give him a
deal of his value they gave him a
three-year deal though that was gonna be
15 million years 18 million guaranteed
that was that's always a running back
that you can look at as a guaranteed
part because majority of time we don't
get to finish our Hoke our whole deal
because the nature of our position so
when lay beyond turns down 19 million
guaranteed and then a week later two
weeks later Tiger Lee gets 45 it makes
sense right and then and then a month
later David Johnson gets 30 and then we
call lady unselfish and say may he you
know like Canadian
sit out they didn't say I'm not gonna
play during a regular season game they
weren't on the franchise tag but he
doesn't have a contract right now he
says he's not under contract right now
Dan then why did his team and I
understand the frustration from the fans
like like when I was nobody but his
teammates mojo his linemen called email
and this is what I say this is what I
said to his linemen if they were so
concerned why didn't they go to the to
the management and have those responses
that that much energy and that much
enthusiasm and say that to Kevin Kolbert
or the Rooney family and said we need to
get him in here and and and not don't
wait till August to do it do it in April
when you're in OTAs in May go out there
and show that type of energy then and
that's what a real teammate does I real
real teammate does that when I held out
my teammates never came out and said Oh
your self is just and that they
understood the business so I I don't I
don't understand from that standpoint
what those players are talking about
when they know they should have had
enough confidence as they did in the
media to go to the management and say
and blame management the same way
Charles hey we did when the Emmitt Smith
was holding out and he went to Jerry
Jones like Jerry what are you doing we
need this guy to win if we're gonna win
we need this guy
maybe the Steelers feel like they don't
need him maybe they don't well we'll see
as the season goes on I don't when do
you think he comes today you you need
players if it was me I if it was me I
wouldn't come back until after week 10
and whenever the last day I have to get
their crude season that's and they
Vincent Jackson did that a couple years
ago came back after week 10 played to
six weeks a free agency and got a big
deal went to Tampa got played played
well in Tampa and was fine so I mean
again teams right now teams are you know
we're in this new CBA where the cap is
going up you have players that are
varied that are playing at an
exceptional level who's gonna get
compensated as such right we don't ask
you a question who would you rather have
on your team right now labium bill or
Sam Bradford
Le'Veon down okay then why can't lay
beyond good 20 million a year then this
end has got a one-year deal for 20
million it's it's the quarterbacking
position that's that's the market he is
you shouldn't you shouldn't do that her
bags are worth that money and when you
pay a quarterback ie what we've seen
before with the Ravens right when they
paid Joe Flacco they couldn't pay anyone
else sometimes it's not the quarterback
it's the other players around you need
to play guys for their value and what
they do for your organization sometimes
if I'm Pittsburgh and I see okay lay
beyond is done XY and Z for me I need to
go out there and make sure that we
compensate him for what he's done and
what he's been he's been one of the top
back if not the top back the last four
or five years in the league I agree and
but it's apples to oranges where you're
saying Sam Bradford too late
no because the position has why does the
quarterback real quick Dan why does the
quarterback why are we okay with the
quarterback making so much money why are
we okay with that way cuz that's the
most important position in all of sports
okay so when when the defense wanted
with the Broncos when Peyton Manning was
not Peyton Manning yep and their whole
defense wanted it wasn't that important
right it's still East and Beyond wanted
when the Seattle Seahawks now there's
certain players like Tom Brady who's the
most important player on his team yes
and Aaron Rodgers yes but a lot of these
other teams that position is not the
most important position on their feet on
their team it's rare to have a team that
goes to the Super Bowl wins the Super
Bowl and you don't have a great
quarterback it's really really sorry Joe
so Nick Foles last year was a great was
he a great quarterback he had a great
game he had great quarterback great know
he had two great games hey what did
there you go he'd been he beat Tom Brady
a team one okay how many how many Super
Bowl MVPs have gone to running backs
no like I don't know no no no no you
can't have as one one can't have it both
ways defense can win MVP Payton who
didn't pay many went in deeper von
Miller one at that yes who else the year
that the Ravens beat the Niners did Joe
Flacco win MVP that year the Sirois VP
when the Raiders when the Ravens beat
the Nutter a Lewis wasn't Ray Lewis the
MVP I don't know I don't I don't know if
Ray Lewis was MVP I don't he was it I
thought it was Joe Flacco okay I I think
that Ray was an MVP in the first Super
Bowl Flacco in the second one yes III
don't have computers here I'm helping my
kids get ready for school okay again I'm
just saying certain teams yes the
quarterback is the most important
position but others is not and so those
teams don't go out there and just say
well we got to pay the quarterback 20
million no you do not you don't have to
do the market has been established at
that position my I have an issue that
the running back I think has been
de-emphasized and there's only a you
have a smaller window at running back
then I feel like at any other position
and it's unfair to them that by the time
you had that first deal and you're done
with five years I don't know if I want
you anymore and you know it's hard for
running backs to get a second big
contract no you're right and I think
when you look at the Cowboys what they
did with DeMarco Murray that was another
situation that you have to pay attention
to and look at where the Cowboys ran
DeMarco Murray that year into the ground
and then let him hit free agency right
and then he end up getting a deal by the
Eagles played a year there the ends of
playing a couple with Tennessee and that
was kind of the end of it but you have
to these are all business decisions that
you have to weigh at the age of 26 right
where a lot of people at the age of 26
aren't weighing these businesses and
understanding that okay if I go out and
play for this 14 million and I get
banged up or I get hurt that's all I get
what kind of limit but why doesn't he do
say getting injured look I'll come back
but I want to split time with James
Conner because Pittsburgh's not going to
do that you can say whatever you want
but once you get in the game Pittsburgh
he's gonna run you we we just saw that
we just saw that on
on Sunday but you're gonna split time
with James Conner that way they how do
we but but but Dan how do we know that
if you get into the crunch time if you
get into crunch time of a game a coach
is going to put his best player out
there regardless okay but you know I'm
gonna put him in for the important plays
there but I'm gonna use James Conner and
maybe I split the carries maybe you're
you're you know I'm gonna cut your
touches in half but I'm gonna use you
when I need to use you for big moments
there that's why I'm paying you fourteen
million dollars this way at least you
get paid we get your services we
understand that you know you don't want
to have the wear and tear here it's a
business decision but we need you in in
uniform here I'll give you I can give
you a better example of that I want to
say it was 2011
I was coming off a knee surgery and the
coaches that kind of came up with a
plate count for me right we didn't want
me to have so many carries by the third
quarter mm-hm and we were in a tight
game with Tennessee and COEs Del Rio
looks up but I had 22 carries into the
third quarter I think they wanted me to
have like 12 he was like what is going
on this is not what we talked about
well they abuse you yeah they abuse Jed
again they abused you this what I'm
saying so once you get into the heat of
the fire and the game and all the
motions going on they're not worried
about a half a play count and what you
guys talked about they're just trying
but their focus is to win the game and
and that's when you utilize your best
players right that's why you saw Big Ben
trying to throw it to a be a ton and if
flavy on said they're gonna definitely
try to get him the ball so you can go in
there and say well hey look you know
give me half the touches and I'll come
in but we know that's not gonna work no
I'm trying to find something he said way
beyond is two years older than Vint a
girl he wasn't born last night he knows
the game and he did it make did it to
allege that he would be young right
early if that was the case in the
department right 39 get the kids off to
school all right I got a I got to go
back to work I wish I could keep talking
to you I miss you guys so much I love
talking to tell all the people man know
your work that are listening and
understand your work when you know your
worth you're never wrong you're fighting
for what's right and that's what lay
beyond is doing thank you
no problem all right talk to you soon
it's Maurice jones-drew that's good
that's fun I like that
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]